Russell Wilson jr. the third just called
in hi Russ how are you know I almost say
that on the highlights that I say
Russell Wilson jr. the third I almost
say it because McLovin is the one who
said that about Robert Griffin jr. the
third so it's a habit now so now I've
been calling you Russell Wilson jr. the
third so glad to have you just let you
know I'm thinking of you when I'm doing
those highlights where are you right now
I mean I'm in California here right on
my bye week right now so I we got we got
a tough Winnick we got a tough win
against the Rams obviously and then we
ended up them coming back down here and
staying down here and so we're getting
that sunshine you know the vitamin D you
don't get very much of it you know that
Rams defense is pretty good did you take
a beating yeah I got hit a couple of
times you know and Donald man that guy
is super special yeah you know you know
you play a lot of great players I've
been fortunate playing it's a lot of
great players and when you find at
playing quarterback when you find that
defensive tackle that maybe arguably one
of the best players on the field every
time you step on the field
that's when you know a guy's really good
because you know you're only thinking
about corners or safeties or or some
linebackers and stuff like that but we
have a defensive tackle inside you know
you know trying to cause havoc that's
that's always a problem so but we were
able to pull through and he came with a
huge win yeah but it almost sounds like
can you hear Erin Donald coming it you
know you can see him but almost he
strikes me as a guy you could hear yeah
I can I I can you can smell me smell um
you kind of just gotta I gotta go you
know it's one of those things that it's
just it's not it's not a pretty sight if
you get there so you know but yeah it's
uh it's one of those things that you can
hear his footsteps and he's a he's fast
man he can really move and so you gotta
kind of wait time ways to get away from
him what is that feeling like to be on
the sidelines when you're watching Jared
golf in the Rams
with the possibility of beating you guys
with the last possession that's a great
question you know honestly we we've been
through a lot you know we've we've
pushed through the test of time man
we've been through some amazing amazing
games and some amazing wins we had some
tough losses and you know actually took
me back to you know after we won that
game it actually took me back and I
remember in 2013 I believe it was you we
won the Super Bowl we we had a tough
game came down to fourth down actually
at the Rams in st. Louis came down to
fourth down there on the five-yard line
going in or something like that and it
took four downs and we stopped him and
you know it was a crazy game was a crazy
a NFC West style football game and sure
enough we were able to pull through and
it kind of made me think back to that
game and you know I think that to be
able to go to where we want to go in any
team lies you watch the baseball
playoffs and NBA Finals you watch
obviously the NFL playoffs and
everything you know it's always about
you know who can who can measure up who
can pull through a tough moment and you
know it's it's those one or two plays
that make a difference and we were able
to do that and you know fortunately you
know our defense made some amazing plays
throughout that game what thought what
is wrong with the offense so Russell
because it feels like the first three
quarters it's kind of conservative or
boring and then all of a sudden it Pete
Carroll says hey Russ go out there and
win the game for us I mean that's the
feeling I get it almost feels like
that's the offensive game plan not that
it is but why is it not consistent or
good well I think I think we're still
growing still getting better I think
that you know we're able to score a
bunch of points there in the second half
of you know the Sunday night game
against the Colts we we were able to you
know score you know I get 10 10 quick
points there in right before half which
was huge in that last game we played and
so you know what it's all about you know
executing and just finishing plays and
finishing drives and being great on
third down and when we do that we're
really tough to beat we'll really tough
to stop and and you know we can score is
me you know you know we got so many
different weapons from Jimmy Graham as
you know it does ball one to lock it and
Paul Richardson we have some guys that
played
really special the other night you think
about Janie McKissack and what he did
the other day you know under the lights
was pretty cool so um you know we're
gonna get hot and we're gonna we believe
in that
he's Russell Wilson jr. the third
joining us Dan Patrick show I hear you
have a new app yeah trace me app it's
pretty uh yeah everybody check it out
you know I'm actually it's been pretty
amazing process we've had some amazing
investors involved and you know drone on
we've had you know we have you know
Bezos and Joe sighs got the big guy yes
yes it's been pretty amazing man and the
whole idea is you know it's a social
media app for force forces leveraging
their super fans think about the thing
about if you're a super fan of you know
Sierra if you're super fan of if you're
super fan of some small team si that
will say the Warriors Revere super fan
you know other athletes or other
celebrities where they are well imagine
if you could go into the world and
really understand the world get VIP
access and get a better understanding of
their world and get exclusive
opportunities to see them backstage or
see them you know pregame or see them
you know get a signed jersey you get the
cleats early you know it's been an
amazing process and amazing development
and it's been overwhelming enthusiasm
behind it and so it's been really
exciting and so you know and we got some
pretty cool people out our CEOs name his
name's Jason Joaquin and he's a really
really special came from the whole world
came from Zulily which is the e-commerce
company from for women which is really
like a company based out of Seattle so
yeah trace me man you know go download
the app trace me it's it's pretty
exciting they're gonna be more
celebrities entertainers coming soon
your way so it's pretty exciting so you
get a sneak peek into my world and kind
of see what that is like
did you just name drop your wife there
well yes she's um she's gonna have her
trace in the account missing me several
others so she's and I know you I know
you know her pretty well yep we're
starting a movie we were coworkers in a
movie co-starred in a movie
exactly she has no idea who she doesn't
remember anything about me
no she does remember you see I was
telling I was a million so right now she
told me to tell you hello so I'm not
sure what that's all about
I I met her at a restaurant st. elmo's
in Indianapolis and there was no spark
Ross just what you know there was no
spark oh good old state house I'm glad
you remember the location and everything
we were down in the basement
we're down to the basement and there was
a lot of people there's a romantic
setting a lot of people there but trust
me
there was no spark just letting you know
Russ you know one of the cool one of the
cool parts that that you know I wanted
to come in we wanted to talk to you
about you know is so I did this funny
thing I think you appreciate you should
do something like this one day but we
went down to the campus maybe maybe you
guys know sometime have a damn practice
show at a university we went down to the
University University of Washington
right down the street and I I dressed up
as a police officer right and me my
security guard would dress up as police
officers and put put a beard on masks on
and everything like that and maybe any
one day which we can surprise the kid
are you able to we were able to hand out
multi grooming kits for these kids and
six different those with six different
attachments and all that but it was
absolutely Harris hilarious and you get
a chance you got it through this video
but I'd love to have you as my as my
guest star one day you know maybe maybe
you and I could be might get by Braun by
Ross the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience